and we saw in Russia a kind of uh
mephistophilian compact between the
state and these hacker groups
[Music]
Nigel Inkster welcome to how the light
gets in thank you very much nice to be
here so I want to talk a little bit
about your most recent book The Great
decoupling China America and the
struggle for technological Supremacy I
want to ask you firstly what led you to
zoom in on China and more specifically
its rise to cyberpower in your work yeah
well I at the time
um that I started thinking about these
things I was working full time for The
International Institute for strategic
studies you know focusing on conflict
International Security and I think it
was 2010 I set up a cyber security
program for the Institute as it became
apparent to me that the Cyber domain was
becoming a zone of international
contestation that had very palpable
geopolitical and International Security
aspects to it and the minute I did that
that I realized that China was going to
be critical
in the evolution or of this Nexus of
technology and power because it had
moved within a relatively short period
of time from being technologically
backward to embracing modern information
communication Technologies and moving
forward very rapidly and with big
Ambitions and you know it was already
clear that this was starting to become
a particular rubbing point between the
United States as the first mover in
these Technologies and China as you know
the country that was running very
rapidly to catch up
and behind all of that you know there
there is a complex Nexus of historical
cultural and and political issues
um and when I was actually asked to
write the book that became the great
decoupling it was actually the
Publishers asked me to do it initially I
thought well I've written about this
already I did an earlier book China
cyberpower and I thought how I got
anything new to say and it turned out
that actually there was a lot and what
really drove it for me was the awareness
that
um within U.S policy circles in
particular
there were a lot of people talking very
confidently and assertively about China
what China was and wasn't what it wasn't
wasn't doing without any real historical
or cultural context you know it was as
if the whole issue had you know sprung
fully formed from the womb and I thought
that it might be useful to try and set
what China is doing in this broader
cultural and historical context and to
go right back to the beginning you know
to period when China had been arguably
the engineering if not scientific
Global superpower responsible in the
pre-industrial revolution era for about
50 percent of the world's inventions
including all the ones that made
possible the age of exploration
so looking at that and then seeing um
how and why you know China firstly why
why China was so successful as a
Technology power but never really
developing a scientific method in the
way that the West was able to do why was
that and
um what were the implications of that
and that you know takes you back in to
the you know early era of
Chinese philosophy about the same time
as that was you know flowering in In
classical Athens you know same sort of
thing you know same sort of processes
same sort of questions
um how these two Traditions had
developed diverged
um and then so to speak China's fall
from Greece due to the fact that China
missed out on the Age of Exploration and
more importantly missed out on the
Industrial Revolution so when confronted
with Western powers that were you know
enabled by you know modern steam driven
and electric technology you know
um Iron clad warships modern artillery
repeating rifles all this sort of thing
they really had no answer and this kind
of plunged China into a kind of
existential crisis and it's been this
you know this you know concern about how
China could re-establish itself as a
major civilizational power without
compromising on it so you know cultural
essence
and this has been a long you know a
prolonged and difficult struggle and
it's still ongoing you know we're we're
we're we're seeing manifestations of
that today so this was really what drove
me to write the book that I you know I
ended up writing and you talk about how
the um how technology is shaping the
geopolitical stage and the geopolitical
conflict between the US and China do you
think there's someone coming out on top
at the moment do you think recent events
have shifted that balance well that is
in a way the kind of sixty four thousand
dollar question and it's very I keep
getting asked this question who's on top
is it America is it China is China
catching up is it overtaking it's a very
difficult question to answer you know
the Technologies don't stand still the
Technologies aren't predictable in in
their development uh sometimes you get
technologies that look you know very
promising and then progress stalls
others move in surprising directions and
open up new possibilities so it's very
very difficult to make confident
predictions about these things
uh what I would say is that China has
um made remarkable progress in catching
up with the United States in in many
areas and in some areas arguably it's
ahead you know Quantum uh encryption for
example is an area where China
constitutes a global Center of
Excellence Chinese Engineers have shown
a remarkable Ingenuity and facility in
developing
um ingenious
applications of existing Technologies
to produce you know consumer facing
products that you know limit or
eliminate the frictions of daily life in
urban China an example being the
pervasive use of you know online finance
and fine and payments to the point where
nobody in China carries cash anymore you
know even beggars uh sit on the street
with you know a sign around their neck
with a QR code you want to give them
money you just you know do it that way
but there are still question marks about
China's
um strength in foundational science I
mean a country of 1.4 billion people has
produced precisely three Nobel Prize
winners thus far and two of them are
actually expatriate Chinese and I
remember a couple of years ago watching
um a YouTube lecture by the senior
editor of China Science and Technology
daily
um making exactly this point he said
China is an engineering uh culture but
we have not yet developed a real culture
of foundational science this is a
serious vulnerability that needs to be
addressed and there are some key areas
where China is behind the United States
and potentially may never catch up an
obvious case in point being
microprocessors you know the most
advanced microprocessors at five and
three nanometer production nodes not
much bigger than the size of a silicon
atom
um uh are beyond the reach of Chinese
companies you know they just can't you
know they haven't got the technology and
the United States has denied them access
to the ultraviolet lithography
technology that would enable them in
principle to do that I was more
complicated than that because this you
know this technology isn't just about
having the care it's about having what
the Germans call fingerspitz cthu this
instinctive knowledge you know the the
the that only comes from doing uh and
it's also about developing complex uh
Supply chains in critical inputs and
ingredients so in areas like this China
is still struggling to to catch up
um it's very difficult to gauge where
China is because the country you know
the the Chinese party State tends to
oscillate between periods of sort of
techno exuberance you know where they're
sort of saying look at China aren't we
doing brilliantly
um combined with periods of
um you know almost despair you know all
we ever going to make it or we ever go
to catch up and it's very very difficult
to get the other point is that these
Technologies
are not
confined to specific Nations you know
progress in this range of Technologies
uh information Communications artificial
intelligence broadly defined Quantum are
the product of international
collaborations
um and complex International
relationships and separating those out
and kind of trying to repatriate them is
going to be a very difficult thing to do
yeah and um interestingly on that I want
to move a little bit away from China and
the US and talk about other Global
Powers so for example Russia has
dominated a lot of the world news are
there is there any technological
capabilities that Russia or indeed other
powers have been developing yeah that
could make them key players on the
global stage that we're perhaps not
paying as much attention to as we should
well I think the short answer is at the
moment no if we look at Russia you know
it's a country that has a very strong
tradition in mathematics and hard
science you know the Soviet education
system was very strong in this regard
and you know Soviet science did produce
some remarkable achievements
um but at the same time the Soviet Union
um was subject to Western technology
embargoes which meant that they never
got access to the big cray computers
which were you know the big story in the
1980s that drove them to do some very in
Innovative foundational science
um which when we found out about it
really kind of took us took us by
surprise but they never really got
um Computing and they certainly didn't
get computer networking which was kind
of antithetical to the Soviets
um preoccupation with protecting
information not sharing information
so when Russia you know emerged
um in the modern world so to speak
um they had a lot of really bright young
graduates in maths physics Etc
um you know the the we saw a lot of uh
interesting software developments but
none of this was ever commercialized you
know there are no Russian or there are
Russian operating systems but nobody
other than Russia would ever buy them
there is a Russian equivalent of
Facebook there isn't a Russian
equivalent of uh Google
um but you know these are specific to
Russia nobody else would use them and
what we found is that a lot of these
Bright Young graduates lacking the
ability to
um apply their skills
um in a sort of productive
um commercially oriented
activities went to the dark side
um and began engaging in cyber
criminality and we saw in Russia a kind
of uh mephistophilian compact between
the state and these hacker groups you
know as long as they were attacking
non-russian targets and as long as they
were making their expertise available to
the Russian State when required they
were pretty left left alone to get on
with it so the net result that all we've
really seen come out of Russia and these
Technologies is malware and I think you
know as much as 80 percent of all the
malware on the planet
um originates from Russia and Kaspersky
you know and could you talk uh in in a
little bit more detail about what cyber
Espionage looks like in today's Global
stage between the US China and Russia
yeah well it's very difficult to form a
comprehensive picture mainly because the
United States and its five eyes allies
are pretty
um laconic about what they themselves
are engaged in and you know there there
is a very you know there there is a lot
of difference
um China is driven primarily by the need
to catch up with the West so what we saw
emerging in the early 2000s was you know
effectively pervasive
um almost kind of wild west
approach to
um state-sponsored um site you know
cyber Espionage everyone was doing it
um eventually you know China was put
under pressure to kind of tighten up
um and
um you know shall we say be more
professional about it in the early days
you know you saw the these exploits
taking place and nobody seemed you know
concerned about concealing the fact that
it was China doing it we've now seen a
tightening up of tradecraft it's better
but it's still pretty obvious that this
is this is China and this is very much
driven by the need to meet some very
demanding targets for China's own
indigenous technology programs so it's
still very much about catching up with
the West at the same time China China's
intelligence Services have realized that
there is a lot of potential to be
derived from Simply stealing large
Western data sets
um which is what they're doing
um really promiscuously sometimes for
counter Espionage purposes some
sometimes kind of attitude
it will get this data and then we'll
work out what we're going to do with it
later so you know there is that but
China is working with purpose
um and strategy Russia is essentially a
disruptive power Russia is a power that
defines its security as a function of
everybody else's insecurity so Russia
you know you know we see Russia on the
international
cyber stage engaging in a lot of
disruptive activity the main aim of
which is is to weaken and put opponents
off balance
when you look at the United States and
its five eyes allies you know they are
you know doing
things in a rather different way
focusing on uh very much State targets
focusing on the ability to do real
damage if they need to but
most of the time keeping their powder
dry and there is I think an interesting
Nexus a kind of inverse ratio between a
state's capacity for soft power and its
propensity to engage in cyber Espionage
so you look at China which struggles to
you know achieve real traction on on
soft power
um you know there's a lot of this stuff
going on you look at the United States
which is a kind of soft power giant
still and Europe
um and and the impetus to engage in
malign activity in the Cyber domain
seems to me you know it seems to be much
less and moving a little bit away from
the Cyber domain and let's talking more
about military strategy so many have
argued and it seems that since the
Russian invasion of Ukraine Russia have
been made to look weak or their military
looks slightly weaker than otherwise was
and some say that's now deterring China
from wanting to invade Taiwan do you
agree with this analysis and what do you
think
okay not in the slightest I mean it's
been very interesting to you know to to
watch Russia's performance so yeah a
much vaunted military modernization
program turns out to be you know a
rather pachomkin exercise
um and as Western experts uh examine
um captured Uh Russian Munitions from
the Ukraine conflict it's becoming
increasingly clear that Russia is
heavily dependent on Western
technology inputs and not being able to
access these because of sanctions is
going to cramp Russia's style very
significantly but the real problem with
Russian military performance in Ukraine
is about you know the fundamental
military culture is less about
technology it's about you know you know
this rather toxic
military culture of
um you know casual violence bullying and
a Soviet mindset which dictates that
units have to wait from for orders from
the top
now China is looking at all of these
things and China has been very
systematically and very methodically
pursuing
military modernization basically since
the first Gulf War when they got the
shock of their lives on seeing you know
U.S Precision guided convey additionally
our Munitions more or less you know sort
of doing everything except stopping at
the red traffic lights in downtown
Baghdad and they realized you know
they've got a lot of catching up to do
and then the Taiwan Straits crisis in
1995-96 gave them a focus for that you
know this is you know every Everything
became about how would we deter the
United States from engaging
um in a war with about Taiwan long
enough for us to achieve our strategic
objective and this has led you know in
into you know major transformation in
terms of military technology
capabilities but also a shift away from
a military Doctrine based on people's
War land-based Mass mobilization uh to
to a military that is now capable of
conducting uh
um complex all arms operations
technologically enabled and technology
is absolutely you know front and center
of of you know the the people's
Liberation Army's uh approach to these
things so basically you know the pla are
looking at what's happened in Ukraine
you know they're learning every lesson
there is to learn
um and of course at the same time the
con the two conflicts are very different
you know Russia Russia Russia has
invaded Ukraine as a land-based army
invading Taiwan is going to be a very
different proposition for for the pla
you've got 110 miles of uh rather choppy
and unpredictable sea you've got
um a very different difficult topography
in Taiwan I mean the Americans thought
about uh an amphibious assault on Taiwan
during World War II and concluded it
would require more resources than the
Normandy Landings so you know moved in
another Direction so you know the China
is going to do this very differently
they're certainly not you know going to
try and avoid making the mistakes that
Russia made though whether they will be
able to develop the military culture
um needed to do this I mean one of the
key things for any effective military is
the non-commissioned officers
you know ncos you know these are people
who don't go through you know a
particular training College
um they're not selected they select
themselves you know they emerge as the
natural leaders
um and the critical interface between
the office decor and the troops China
has only a very embryonic NCO culture
they've only had it you know that for
you know relatively short period of time
so I think there is still a big question
mark about whether the pla in a combat
situation would be able to manifest the
local autonomy and Agility
um that Modern Warfare requires you know
or whether they would have to sit there
and wait for orders to come from on high
there were rumors that after the Russia
invasion of Ukraine China actually
delayed their Invasion into Taiwan and
we're going to launch some kind of
military offensive at least those rumors
have been flying about what's the source
of those rumors and what would your
comments be I have no idea what the
source of the rumors is but my comments
are I think is it it's mostly nonsense
um you know I've been watching the
Taiwan situation uh very closely one of
the exercises I do for in order company
I work with is for a select group of
clients a monthly Taiwan watch where we
you know monitor this month in month out
what's changed you know how does that
you know affect the you know the the
risk in terms of hard numbers at the
moment I think it is still the case that
China
um
wants to be able to recover Taiwan
without having to resort to force that
possibility is receding Over the Horizon
I think there's no question about it
I don't yet think that the Chinese
leadership have reached the Tipping
Point at which they conclude peaceful
reunification is no longer an option I
think they are coming closer to that and
I think they are coming closer to it as
a result of recent American activities
um both you know independently and in
collaboration with with allies
and I think it may well be the case that
the Chinese leadership will soon come to
that conclusion I don't think they have
yet but it is something you know that's
very important for Xi Jinping as the
current leader he has said in terms that
the great Rejuvenation of the Chinese
nation is kind of signature policy if
you will cannot be achieved without
National reunification
so Taiwan has got to be recovered and Xi
Jinping is a man with a sense of his own
destiny he will hope that this can be
done in his lifetime and what sort of
policy or military action taken by the
U.S could push China to the point where
they think that peaceful reunification
with Taiwan is no longer an option that
is an almost impossible question to ask
actually
um but I think it is a combination of
supplying ever more sophisticated
equipment to Taiwan such that Taiwan
would be able to deploy a so-called
porcupine strategy using asymmetric
capabilities to make
the pla's life very difficult combined
with with actions that would suggest to
China unequivocally that the U.S and
allies would be willing to intervene
militarily in support of Taiwan I think
there's those two things coming together
I mean the other thing is Declaration of
Independence by Taiwan but that is the
most unlikely contingency the irony in
all of this is the biggest thing
stopping
the DPP the ruling Taiwan party from
declaring independence is the United
States telling them don't you you know
don't you dare do this so what should
the US's strategy be then
well that is very interesting because I
think the USA has kind of got themselves
you know out on a limb here and it goes
to the point that the sort of U.S focus
in the Asia Pacific and as they now like
to call the indo-pacific Region
is very much dominated by the military
option
and it was a great
shame that
um well you never remember the exact
um
acronym for this organization that Obama
suggested the Trade Organization of the
Asia Pacific region CPE
PCC I think that that that's it it was
something that Donald Trump pulled out
of uh because this is I think the big
thing that's lacking in in U.S policy in
the region is is a convincing
um commercial and economic presence that
would actually act as an alternative
pull to to China's attraction Biden
Administration is now trying to put
something in place but at the moment it
looks pretty anemic quite honestly
really offering these countries what
they what they want
um the other thing I you know and so I
think this problem is that you know the
the USA has now sort of caught up in
this
um
Dynamic the the
determination to remain the hegemonic
power which is kind of understandable
um is driving this and in that context
you know it's important to bear in mind
taiwan's role as part of the first
island chain you know they're this line
of islands from Japan through the
Philippines through Taiwan to Borneo
that runs right along China's Eastern
Seaboard and potentially uh constrained
China's you know freedom for Action
um in Naval terms losing Taiwan
breaches the first island chain and
fundamentally reshapes the geopolitics
of the Asia Pacific region
and this is something that you know
obviously the United States is anxious
to avoid you know worth is to be
breached you know relations with key
allies notably Japan South Korea would
be quite fundamentally changed Donald
Trump
um during his presidency decided to
launch a series of aggressive trade Wars
yes against China and in the chronology
of the US's relationship with China how
did that affect it and what impacts is
that still happening today
well
um you know in in a sense I think you
know the trade and Tech was that Donald
Trump launched kind of had to come
because China was you know fairly
shamelessly gaming the International
System and had been since it joined the
World Trade Organization in 2001 you
know it was taking everything and you
know not giving much back in terms of
offering Market access exchange rates
um you know openness you know um you
know opening you know capital accounts
all of these things China you know
didn't do that and you know precisely
because China didn't do that
um you know we we saw the emergence of a
massive savings club that provoked the
2008 financial crisis so though you know
obviously the main blame for that has to
lie with feckless and irresponsible
um U.S Bankers uh China's own behavior
was not you know China was not Guiltless
in this you know that date 2008 was I
think think a Tipping Point a moment of
epiphany for the Chinese leadership a
moment at which they concluded the
Washington consensus was a false god and
they needed to do something different
and better and it was a point at which a
lot of pent-up pressures in the U.S
China relationship kind of burst out and
at that point we began to see a China
that was much more assertive
Unapologetic about what it was and what
it aspired to be and more explicitly and
overtly challenging U.S Global hegemony
and you know the U.S led International
order which is where we are now and we
you know what we've you know been seeing
for the last sort of 12 15 years is
essentially a sort of
Progressive development of these Trends
so I think where we are now is is in a
very bad place in a very worrying place
um I think that the Chinese leaders the
current Chinese leadership
um increasingly sees relations with the
United States in zero sometimes
everything that they now say about the
United States is negative and critical
um you know they they they perceive that
the United States will do anything it
can to prevent China from
achieving its you know our apotheosis if
you like you know emerging on on the
global stage as as a major
civilizational power and there are low
China you know they're they're you know
Mantra is you know the East is rising
the West is in Decline they see United
States as a power in terminal decline
this has become Dogma unassailable you
know the fact is they do realize that
the United States still has the capacity
to frustrate China from what it's trying
to do and I think this is you know one
of the drivers for the um so-called No
Limits relationship with Russia that was
declared you know earlier this year just
before the Ukrainian invasion you know I
mean this is a marriage of convenience
you know between Russia and China but
they share the same objective which is
to Break
um you know the U.S hegemonic hold on
the world and to Institute a new Global
Order driven by a small number of great
Powers China Russia and yes the United
States each with its own sphere of
influence and able to activate on act
unconstrained within that sphere of
influence such as the sort of vision I
think that they're they are now pursuing
and talking about this China Russia
Alliance so where do you think the
threat of that stand in the context of
where their economies are at the moment
is it underestimated or is it quite no I
think as long as Vladimir Putin and Xi
Jinping are in their respective
positions you know this um you know the
commitment of the mutual commitment will
will be undiminished
um I mean I think China is probably
pretty unhappy about the way you know
the Ukraine conflict has progressed so
I'm pretty sure Putin told them that it
was going to be over in three days a
quick decapitation and then you know
back to business as usual and they will
you know China's leadership will have
been dismayed and discontinence firstly
by the fact of Russian incompetence but
secondly by an unexpected show of
Western determination and and resilience
which clearly gives China a pause for
thought but no I mean I think you know
the the if you look at the kind of
geopolitics of it
um this relationship
makes perfect sense and and it does you
know over the long term offer
considerable Mutual benefit firstly
having a good relationship with Russia
frees China up from the need to heavily
police this long land border and you
know
gives them the license that they needed
to to focus their efforts on developing
Maritime military capabilities so you
know that that in itself is a major plus
secondly there is a degree of
complementarity uh China you know is
energy hungry Russia is energy rich
um Russia is actually you know uh behind
China in terms of
commercialized modern technology hence
benefits from this you know the military
relationship is you know a bit more
fraught with particularly in in relation
to arms sales because until recently
Russia has been the dominant player in
arms sales China is now catching up and
overtaking Russia and I think the
Russian
state is kind of resigned to the
inevitability that over time China will
you know replace
um Russia as as a major arms
manufacturer and arms purveyor but they
can kind of live with that and I think
essentially what you've got is a
situation in which both parties realize
that Russia is a junior partner China is
smart enough not to rub
Russia's nose in it
um you know there is quite a lot of
complementarity
um but you know this the the the there's
always this like the artificial forced
element to this bear in mind that China
has irredentous claims on large sways of
uh Russian territory in Siberia and if
you read Colin thubran's latest book
along the Amor you realize that there
are people to people basis there is no
love lost between the two
where does the Middle East lie in all of
this and what's their significance will
the Middle East in a very interesting
area it depends which bit of it you're
talking about
um but the kind of you know
um actually the the sort of you know
sort of economic political and Military
you know Power Center is Saudi Arabia
and the Gulf States you know these
wealthy you know oil-based economies
um and they I think are in an
interesting state of geopolitical flux
for some while now they've been
questioning the reliability of the U.S
security guarantee
and increasingly thinking that they have
to strike out on their own and we've
seen some very you know significant
developments not always particularly
successful I mean Saudi Arabia's war in
Yemen being a classic example of kind of
how not to do it uh but the fact is
they've done it you know they've
exercised strategic autonomy they've
taken the decision to do this we're
seeing you know the United Arab Emirates
um ingata
making kind of independent plays in in
various uh regards militarily
economically and I think we will see
more of this you know we're seeing it's
very interesting for example that
um you know Saudi Arabia The Keeper of
the two holy places of Islam had nothing
to say about what China was doing to
co-religionaries uh in xinjiang nothing
at all
um and then this is simply a function of
geopolitical pragmatism you know they
they need China
um they need a a good and collaborative
uh relationship with China you know
China needs a you know oil and gas you
know they need Chinese investment
um so you know they are going to pursue
this very pragmatic and unideological
course in developing relations with
China and I think you know they are a
kind of extreme example of the
dilemma and challenge but also
opportunity that most medium-sized
Powers now face you know coming under
pressure to choose
not wanting to do so and looking to
create
um
space for autonomous Behavior either
individually or in
um you know ad hoc and pragmatic
alliances with other like-minded players
and I think that's what we're now seeing
Nigel internet thank you very much
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to The Institute of Arts
and ideas at IAI TV